- It's like saying, "Oh
yeah, you can go cheat
"and I'll just forgive you.
"Everything will be okay later."
No, no, that's not how it work.
I am not Boo Boo the Fool.
Beyonce is not Boo Boo the Fool.
- Living in a world of hookup culture,
people are constantly
looking for something better
or what's next.
Even Jay-Z just dropped
an album addressing
a lot of the rumors we heard on Lemonade.
So I'm just gonna walk around the office
and ask, "Could you forgive
someone for cheating on you?"
- Yes, I have cheated on someone.
- I have not.
- I don't think they know.
- I have not been cheated
on, to my knowledge.
- One time, that I'm aware of.
- I've actually been cheated on
on two of my serious relationships.
- I've definitely been cheated on,
and I've definitely cheated to be petty.
- I can understand why people would cheat.
It doesn't make it right, but sometimes
things happen in life.
- I feel like emotional
cheating's actually a big thing
even if you're thinking of
someone in a way, that is to me--
- That's cheating.
- Almost worse.
- I feel like if you're a
rapper or a basketball player,
it's just easier.
- You can't help your attraction.
But, with that being said, your attraction
should not be open while
you're in a relationship.
- If you feel like you have to cheat,
I feel like you should just
get out of that relationship.
- If I'm married, I'm not
gonna leave my husband
for cheating.
If it's something that happened once.
- Does that mean you get
back together with them
and forgive them enough to
keep the relationship going?
Or do you forgive them
enough where it's like
you're kind of okay with
the choices they've made
as a person?
- I feel like you forgive somebody
if you're the family or you
have some sort of history
or past.
I think it's tough for people
just to leave that behind.
- As a single person with no children,
for me, cheating is a deal-breaker.
- I would forgive them
because that's just how I am
and that's my morals but I would not stay
in a relationship with them.
- Obviously, your life is now devoted
to your kids and your family
but you at the end of the day
need to be happy.
- Forgiveness is the way to
move on and grow but it's
really difficult.
(slow urban music)